hi in Mexico Sierra Madre Mountains as a
revolution taking place an uprising by
ordinary people against the gangs and
drug cartels that have threatened and
terrorized this region for decades
through filthy weather along dirt tracks
and flooded roads we were taken deep
into vigilante territory our destination
a secret prison its existence just a
rumor until now we're the first
outsiders to be accepted in
the inmates hang out of the barred
windows of the converted municipal
building there's no proper court of law
up here they've just been taken off the
streets by the vigilantes a clean up
operation as unique as it is illegal
inside
we beat Leonardo he's 22 although he
seems much younger his youthful looks
hide inner Enders history of violence
for the Knights Templar drug cartel
leonardo has killed 19 people in the
past three years why did you do it
I've been in bad companions I have bad
friends and they they push me to bad
stuff cartels traditionally paid for
kills to take place but exploiting his
naivety and age leonardo killed because
he was told quite simply that if he
didn't he would be killed instead the
authorities say that's not unusual that
does go to the to the point of this
problem is that people are killing for
virtually nothing
well perhaps apart from staying alive
which was in peace on this Amman era una
vez que yes Lebanon a contaminant osela
Buddhism lozenger por una manera natural
these inmates aren't all cartel members
but they've been identified as
anti-social troublemakers and criminals
as well david says he's in for alcohol
related crimes although when pressed
does admit that there is another
investigation into an alleged murder
that he is said to have committed how
long's expert to be here
no porn oh man little one
listen to the tree huh Nozick want to
miss a boy one you put this on well no
no sir I will never play the law in the
[Music]
traditions here are grim for sure
they're much better than any Mexican
federal prison now said it's hardly a
proper facility to rehabilitate or for
that matter punish but a vigilante
groups believe that away from a system
that is almost completely corrupt they
will achieve more with these people this
is tough justice for sure the community
acting on its own without any proper
legal process it raises questions about
the sort of convictions that they've got
and also the fact that there's a mix-up
of people so we've got boys in here who
are basically drinking too much causing
trouble at home as well we have a
murderer at 19 people assassinated by
him for the drug cartels mixing them up
together of course is not the best
practice but it is what this community
is doing is it attempts to wrest control
back from the drug cartels the vigilante
control of their areas is sporadic a
volunteer force the patrol street and
man's checkpoint to keep their streets
safe Outsiders like us can't travel with
any real freedom
we were stopped regularly by this armed
militia refused entry they are of course
protecting this mountain prison an old
man accused of cartel membership enjoys
a meal delivered by his family the
inmates are reasonably well treated here
but this is the best meal he'll get just
once a week and it always ends with him
returning to his cell it's a strange
place up here
it's ngayon impossible to escape
Leonardo is watched over by a single
guard as he buys sweets and pop from a
shop before returning to his cellmates
the cartels haven't gone of course but
the vigilante control village is
desperately poor as they are remain for
now at least
peaceful federal law and order tainted
with corruption has failed these people
this is their fight back the prison a
symbol of their success to arouse a Sky
News Mexico